cher journal je me demande combien de
villes me faudrait pour tout faire ma
mère me répète sans cesse que je ne
termine jamais rien mais c'est faux il
ya des choses que j'ai terminé friends
par exemple j'ai vu toutes les saisons
en moyenne trente fois et je recommence
un épisode à chaque fois que doit
terminer un projet et jean ne lâche rien
je regarde en intro que tu en dises
maintenant j'ai terminé la première page
de l'odyssée les luges les relu jusqu'à
comprendre ce que les phrases voulait
dire j'ai terminé le début de cinq
courts métrages
j'ai terminé de sortir tous les
vêtements mon placard pour commencer à
faire le tri de ce que je gardais ce que
je donne
mais la vérité c'est que je n'ai pas
envie d'aller au bout de tout ce que je
commence j'ai besoin d'avoir des choses
à finir pour avancer le jour où tout
sera bouclé il faudra bien que je trouve
une nouvelle activité a avorté
et quand j'aurai tout terminer que me
restera t-il le vide tu appelle ça de la
satisfaction
et bien moi j'appelle ça la dépression
anna ne termine jamais rien mais encore
heureux que je ne termine jamais rien ça
veut dire que je suis en vie maman ça
devrait être assuré sa maman alors oui
j'ai encore acheter un nouveau carnet
alors que je n'ai pas terminé les 34
précédent
c'est vrai j'ai sorti tout mon matériel
de peinture à l'huile et je me suis
arrêté à la sous-couche d'accord jeunes
étoiles et écoles côté gauche de mon
chien je me suis inscrite au code il n'y
suis allé que deux fois mais c'était il
ya douze ans le code a changé maman
depuis ce pas de ma faute si mon horloge
indique 12h23 depuis que je les achetais
mis les piles étaient vendus séparément
quelle idée aussi franchement une figure
toi que c'est agréable quand le temps
s'arrête moment je me suis fait tatouer
la moitié de carpediem parce que ça
faisait un petit peu mal ça j'avoue
d'accord mais figure toi que je laime
comme ça mon demi tatouage maman c'est
même exactement rendu que j'espérais
turin alors évidemment que j'avais prévu
de terminer cette page de journal en à
l'endroit où le fera je me ferai peut
être une prochaine fois où peut-être pas
mais au moins je suis en vie maman et si
ça ne te fait pas plaisir à leur écoute
je sais pas quoi dire c'est peut-être
aucun problème après tout
de toute façon que je fasse que je fasse
pas t'es jamais contente alors autant ne
rien faire non
[Musique]